Putin is a middle of the road guy
compared to the hardliners pergoian
wants martial law and nuclear war with
the West he's completely psychotic I've
watched his videos where he says it and
he's Fearless too he's out on the front
lines for like a year and a half the
guy's a maniac
and so I mean Patrick what do you think
I mean the bottom line is the bottom
line is Oh yeah exactly let's cheer get
rid of Putin yeah then there'll be a
whole new power struggle and you'll get
a much more radical Russia what do you
guys and that's why Soros in the west
were crazy nine years ago to overthrow
the Ukrainian government and then run
these Ops against the Russians to get
them to come in just make no mistake I'm
not for the Russians either but the West
started this you're basically saying be
careful what you wish for you want Putin
out of there who's next in line